As we will see, one of the operating system's role is to control access of the
applications to physical hardware. So a basic understanding
of hardware components and how they interact is
essential to the course. Let's do a quick
review. What better way to start the review
than by a fun quiz. Now in this
quiz, I'm showing you the hardware continuum that exists
today in terms of the devices that you and I are using on an everyday basis.
Smartphones all the way to the cloud and
a lot of data points inbetween. There are tablet's,
and laptops. There are desktop computers. There are
servers. And of course, the cloud computing itself that
you may have heard of, that is being
enabled by data centers. So this is a hardware
continuum that you're looking at. And the question that I'm posing to
you is, is the internal organization of computer system in this continuum,
going all the way from smartphone to the cloud. Is this vastly
different? That's the question. And it's a binary answer. Yes or no.